this week we've got raised finger
controversial campaign and fried hot tub
my favorite fried hot dog fried finger
wait fried hot dog is just hot dog on a
stick
ok but we'll talk about that later right
yeah we're talk about the raise finger
first we always stick to the order yeah
I raised my finger before I picked my
nose hmm all right so this billboard
went up and it's a billboard advertising
aid someone's birthday divorce services
love people be buying billboards like
are they cheap as hell no yeah probably
I don't know
so this billboard was raising my brows
but my favorite kind of billboards to
see right here on this freeways are the
lawyer ones and the real estate ones
because they always have to have clear
the [ __ ] Chinese guy that's
everywhere James Wayne yeah everywhere
in Rowland Heights every [ __ ] bubble
he's also on like placemats
- yeah restaurant the only ones I see is
the white guy with the Asian lady noise
yeah I'm like just because I saw your
faces now I don't want to work with you
guys there's this one in LA whole star
gym and it's always like telling people
to get checked for aids and stuff but
it's always like two or three like dudes
on there that look hella [ __ ] pissed
but they're also holding each other an
affectionate way so it's kind of weird
cuz it almost gives you this feeling
like wait are you trying to say that all
gay guys have eight yeah the ad comes
out so it looks like this is kind of
offensive more on the like west side
where there's a whole bunch of doctor
billboards yeah the one with the family
yeah they buy them like back to back so
yeah Pelphrey latest but you could see
like three or four billboards of the
same doctor with this family but doing
different that sounds like either West
Side of Beverly Hills - no that's the
Santa Monica exit yeah yeah yeah that
guy's been buying that billboard for
like the last 10 years
I think wife is a doctor - right yeah I
don't know but it's funny because that
billboard is all about his ego
like look at me in my [ __ ] dress like
look at me and my family
he wears a dress well what I'm wearing
like the doctor dress no like he's
wearing a nice suit like it like that
like what give me dressed dressed up
just like a doctor would be funny if
he's wearing like a kimono or something
that'd be tight yeah but that would just
be like just a flex on everyone to be
like I can wear whatever I want
you're still kind of yeah oh Danny's
cocky dress it's hella cocky though if
you want if you look at that billboard
it's like look at how awesome my life is
and my family is it's like what the [ __ ]
but also that's the whole point of the
billboard it's to flex on all the other
doctors cuz we just saw that that one
billboard costs $2,000 I don't know how
much a billboard in LA costs but if he's
buying all these out constantly he's
flexing with just the Billboard purchase
dude I've been listening to a lot of
[ __ ] what's-his-face the [ __ ] Gary
Vee got AV man dude he's like everything
I want to say but I don't do you know I
mean you know like what are you saying
that I know that I should do but I don't
do you know I feel lazy yeah but dude
he's so [ __ ] do what he said he goes
it's better to smile in a Toyota than
crying your Lamborghini my Honda Element
too so you kind of [ __ ] up on that so
but on you Gary I'm always crying yeah I
think I'd rather crying Lamborghini
know I have to try him again because how
many people recommend heaven I was like
oh yeah I'll put it on TV yelling at me
like I did he's pretty intense I was
like Gary what the [ __ ] I'm actually
doing okay and he was like no you don't
wake up every morning wake up at 3:00
a.m. before your enemy he's not talking
to you I felt personal shopper he's not
mean to people like me I mean it's like
like I like I was like no it was just
too much I mean maybe I'll try I mean is
he good for me like I can't listen to
like maybe him podcast every day but he
has a lot of gems but I really do [ __ ]
he does have a lot of gems so it's just
that it's kind of hard for people when
you know some people just don't take
information like that very well but most
of those gems also require more work
Oprah [ __ ] like take that information
well but I felt like he was about to
come out of my TV in
he's like the same height as you though
he's not intimidated he was about to
[ __ ] me up and so I turned it off to
protect motivates you by calling you a
stupid [ __ ] I know Gary I'm doing okay
so how you do in the war do you wake up
and do something about it if you don't
your [ __ ] [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
buy my book like he would say something
and then I'd be processing it and I was
like well as this message to me was a
can you [ __ ] don't do you when I was
little it's not for you I think he's the
perfect counter to people that are lazy
or people that are kind of like
petrified like they know they want to do
something they just can't take that step
or because I mean he's perfect for an
antiquey custom tailors what he's saying
based off of who's listening so he knows
the podcast and stuff like that oh
that's smart I actually went to one of
his dinners and like like a keynote
speech that he did and I saw a drastic
difference even within that because the
people at the dinners they're all
business professionals are paying
thousands of dollars to sit down and
then see him and all that talk so so he
doesn't have to sit there and motivate
people all of that was just strategy
marketing advertising where what the
next move should be in your business
right and then the keynote speech was a
lot different it was more for for people
that didn't quite understand social
media so I'm like oh that's dope he
knows his audience yeah who he's talking
to
so I think the podcast is more like the
person that's sitting at home like um
who's this guy
good morning [ __ ] bags yeah basically
that's really smart though to be like
you know to tailor to that cuz I felt
like in the podcast he sat down he was
like such a piece of [ __ ] yep I feel
like David Goggins would be that here's
one note regardless of where he is you
catch him on the street [ __ ] [ __ ]
you'll say that to Richard Branson dude
what the [ __ ]
David Goggins like he got me motivated I
literally took 8% of what he did and
then afterwards I was like you're a
[ __ ] psychopath dude that's why I
like him so I didn't get to show you
guys this billboard oh wow this is
little bored I like it given the middle
finger
it's the ring finger saying I'm done
divorce $4.99 We the People oh I thought
it was the middle finger I don't meet
you that's really good a lot of people
are like oh they shouldn't have they Oh
suck my dick it's funny I feel like that
so I like it when a girl says suck my
dick it's the funniest thing to me when
a girl gets mad at somebody go suck my
[ __ ] dick
it is hilarious she had white smell good
too
all right all right he's giving you some
lovely words of affirmation yeah she had
a dick it was smell nice yeah like Bath
& Body Works would it be the same to you
she says that my [ __ ] no because you
wanna do because that's an invite for
creeps and it's not a mat it's not an
imaginative anymore so girl said that'd
be like I don't know I think for a guy
when a girl says I say give me a [ __ ]
orgasm
yeah but girl says suck my dick I'll be
like your tie it's just weird like I
always thought that was the dumbest
thing because the most homophobic guys
would say suck my dick like saying you
want what what are you talking about
this yeah it would just be weird yeah
but when a girl says it hilarious it's
funny all right moving on to the next
story
so Australia's Northern Territory is
cracking down on this unofficial tourism
slogan
and it says see you and the NT in the NT
[ __ ]
ah so if this is this private that's
kind of tight doesn't offend me at all
because I don't have any history with it
but it's a little bit stronger all right
so it's worse than [ __ ] it is
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah Casey like saying
that word that's why in the do you like
it oh my he also likes Earl Grey tea I
think he does actually with milk yeah
to you is enough yeah have you ever had
to youth bugs I love it it's right yeah
okay I hate this this is an independent
brand this is being an [ __ ] I'm here
oh it's alright uh so this is an
independent brand called
unofficial NT unofficial and so they
created all this merch see you and the
NT and so a lot of people are like what
the hell that's so offensive
what's awesome about it cuz it spells
cut if you put the word I mean okay i'ma
play devil's advocate on this so
personally I don't like overly offensive
things just like in public you know like
if I like I'm like I don't get offended
by stuff but like I don't always want to
see it or like you know like if there's
a fat hairy dick on a t-shirt okay so I
went to a coffee shop one time I went to
this coffee shop in LA and I'm standing
there getting my coffee and I see this
girl walk in and she has a purse and
it's a Photoshop photo and like it has a
patch sewn onto it and it's a Photoshop
photo of Trump naked in the middle of
like an orgy like sucking dick and like
getting like combed all over whoa it's
7:30 in the morning okay like I did not
ask to start my day like this and like
this car you don't need coffee anymore
either I didn't I didn't want it that
[ __ ] can go to jail though she she
looked like super feminist like wearing
a shirt said the future hairy armpits
all that and so like the rainbow t-shirt
she wants somebody to say cincture so I
didn't say anything obviously but like I
don't want to see that like sometimes
like even if you don't get offended by
this stuff like you don't always want it
like up in your face what about that do
you see the word cuz I don't even see
them oh I don't give a [ __ ] like seems
like you kind of sympathize with the
people that are cool with this yeah they
don't personally when her case is
extreme like if a kid is seeing that on
her so you go to jail
yeah yeah she couldn't go to jail [ __ ] I
stopped so mad at that girl that was
obnoxious
of course she's just I mean for her
she's just trying to put like she wants
people to see that so people could start
a conversation with yeah they want she
wants them I just smell her Bo
she wants people to get tangled in her
[ __ ] unkept hair she was up at 7 a.m.
because she didn't go to sleep yet she
[ __ ] woke articles and she's like
well [ __ ] it
gotta get my woke coffee please yeah
politician it is good whatever but it's
the hole it's the nudity and the like
offensiveness and the brass that's like
calm the [ __ ] down what I don't
understand is how can you have so much
hate for someone you never met before
that's what that's just crazy that's
insanity really like I understand if you
if you met someone and you're like that
[ __ ] I hate that person because
they did this to me if you never met
them you don't really know their
character you just only know what
character you're given I think it's all
tribalism you know 100 percent is that
yeah it's just tribalism it's like you
know the people that hate Trump have a
hive mind
so they gravitate towards each other and
I think it's less about hating the
politics or hating because half them
don't even read like I'm not defending
like I'm not I'm not like I support or
anything but like you seem like a
supporter they don't even read the
policies but they're just you know hive
mining together like on this thing but
they think they're actually woken they
have the answer yeah that's everybody
though on both sides like I hate
politics I'm so centralist yeah I don't
I can't I can't do it it's too stressful
like people like me should not do much
information good it's too much right
there with you yeah because politics
it's not about politics about money
that's what they don't understand they
think it's about emotions and decisions
based off of you know people's morals
and [ __ ] like that it's not it's all
about money that's why I say you know
I'm gonna say this I should not vote
because I'm not gonna sit down and read
all these articles I should not have
control over what happens so if you
really get out there and vote I'm like
well I need to get out there and read
first and I don't have time for that
it's too much it's too much so I trust
all about democracy either
there's too many cooks in the kitchen
and then you want all these idiots to
[ __ ] run your life [ __ ] no no is that
when Trump entered that plane he had
umbrella it isn't [ __ ] said
dropped right did you see that [ __ ]
no funniest thing ever I do you see that
sure he went like this
ball that's [ __ ] you look like a
different person dude that's just
hilarious didn't realize we had a to
play on and he like just pulled it off
and he was just straight up ball wrong
it was pretty funny it's good I bet you
if he was bald then he would have lost
the election cuz you know how image
plays such a big [ __ ] wall yeah this
hair is like you look like a different
person it's better though with the
toupee or not also they could have maybe
done the color it had a little gray look
match for two men they got some dope
toupee technology Dino you should read
it to critic gate big at the back of his
hair and it just like the bother but no
[ __ ] the [ __ ] where they glue that
[ __ ] they shave their head and they glue
it on like Dom did that [ __ ] cuz Dom's
been losing his hair oh wow he did a
whole video on Tom Dietrich's what yeah
you do see the video that he did no so
he's been doing head spin this whole I
don't have hair on my shins yeah yeah
yeah yes so like it's been so he's been
dealing with baldness for a very long
time now
yeah this will did a whole video on it
it's [ __ ] hilarious off his head this
dude [ __ ] dope is held in a whole
video that's done I saw chance he's so
[ __ ] dope man I respect his dude a
million thousand percent and this guy so
he shaved his head yeah and they put
like that gluing hair transplant that
you should be seeing on YouTube it looks
[ __ ] amazing Wow yeah it looks so
he's been hiding it by opportunity the
whole comb-over [ __ ] so like the bald
spots that he had from all those head
spins it's just not coming back so is
that fake hair it's not like a implant
and they kind of girls no no so you I
think you have to get it redone every
like month or something but it looks
[ __ ] good if I go bald I'm doing that
[ __ ] dude 100% I hope I don't go me yeah
you know Joe you got a good head of hair
you got to take that hat off man thank
you
yeah if I do it with the plan
makes no difference dude your hair has
so much volume there's so much of it
I'll leave it all good hair your hair is
so [ __ ] thick your hat can't even
press it down oh man my head actually
starts hurting after like a couple hours
when I'm wearing a hat dude what's press
down and it wants to go up like Marge
Simpson dude when I have a hat on and it
presses it down my head looks like the
back of a seal like it's just my friend
your [ __ ] is up like your hat bounces
off and you have like do it like a
preceding hairline like I've got to head
we look look at this I have a to head
yeah
you two have to think after you die a
tree is gonna grow from your head you
sons of [ __ ] dude wow you got nice
hair too but that is Korea we have two
heads when I look at their hair I get
[ __ ] jealous I've had been here since
I was a kid right so I might not thick
and full but you know for a long time I
got I was jealous of thin hair because
how many diverse styles yeah you can
comb it so many different ways you could
manipulate it there's a lot of different
stuff I I can't have that many hair yeah
but when I jump into a pool of water it
looks like somebody chewed on my hair
when you jump into it just like a
beautiful helmet it's hair I mean it's
hair it's hard to control I get [ __ ]
nervous sometimes always that's my ball
my ball being goes nah they just got in
here don't worry about it
I like your [ __ ] hair lines fine
there's no bald spot you're good but I
get scared yeah alright moving on to our
last story KFC is crowdfunding on
IndieGoGo to develop a hot tub
KFC hot tub Kentucky Fried hot why do
they need a Go Go whatever yeah we got
trillions of dollars let's hear this
yeah that's kind of interesting so they
have this thing called KFC innovations
labs where they just keep inventing
things and they're crowdfunding it but
you can come hot tub uh-huh does the
chicken come in a tub oh my god I never
even thought of it so I'll show you guys
a video then
cleaning it well that's awesome that's
pretty cool
I want that that's better you just feel
the tension melting away wood-fired hot
tub features rugged craftsmanship you're
the chicken bro technology yard branding
to make your neighbors hungry
oh you know be dull good if it smells
like chicken well what was that those
were some good invention he's talking to
me does that sound like something you'd
like to see brought to light and I shows
tiny thing breakthrough inventions
literally and I need your help support
this crowdfunding campaign today and KFC
innovations lab will really turn this
innovation idea is the innovation
reality yo man I I feel like I love KFC
now no I want a KFC hot tub that's tight
I got food poisoning on KFC I haven't
been a believer since but I want to go
back and how long ago is this they need
to bring back the rotisserie gold 14
they need to bring back the rotisserie
gold it's been that many years since
I've actually I think it's time yeah and
I only like extra crispy because
something happened with the classic
because it's just not the damn same yes
I'm disappointed to find out that the
KFC hot tub has nothing to do with fried
chicken I was hoping for maybe some type
of food they would come out maybe like a
little fryer on this and it's like a
wood-burning one so it's really ancient
I mean look look not to like set my race
back a couple years or anything but like
I love chicken I do like I'm all up you
should all be ashamed a fried chicken
that sucks all black people have to like
hide and eat fried chicken because of
the whole like history and racism and
all that yeah she probably loved it I
[ __ ] love fried chicken
who doesn't love it it's more like weird
if you don't love fried chicken if you
don't eat fried chicken something's
wrong with you that's true
chicken wings are one of my favorite
things on earth I could eat chicken
wings every day you like that are there
drumsticks or thighs meat two battles
and thighs are my favorite greens are my
favorite
way more money yeah it used to be it
used to be but then the skin to meat
ratio yeah it's not the best that's a
good ratio it's a good ratio it's the
perfect ratio
I like thighs because especially do it
good you bite it right and it's crispy
like a mother fast true if that one is
juicy it's almost like someone busted
nuts in your mouth
that's true 19 why do you like [ __ ]
chicken wings on a chicken thighs
because it feels like somebody came in
me juice not wrong I feel like everyone
says that happened before we're like you
bite into it and that's when it's a good
thing yeah burns you yeah it is Bert it
it's like wow yeah then you gotta get
sweet tea I want drugs yeah curious in
order for you to obtain your own fried
hot tub Kentucky Fried hot tub you've
got a donator what is it pledge 13,000
what book and $11 Oh your bite you're
basically buying one for yourself yeah
but so their goal it's a fixed goals
which means if they don't reach this
goal then no one gets anything and their
goal is forty six thousand six hundred
and eighty three dollars so like three
or four hot tubs but as of now it's
three hundred and thirty-five dollars
have been raised by eight backers three
hundred and thirty-five dollars yeah
nobody's gonna buy that [ __ ] you're a
billion dollar company you could do it
yourself I know what the [ __ ] I'm
confused that is so weird
so yeah cuz there are other things that
they have is Colonel on ice ice skating
show that they're also putting on indigo
that's a pretty good idea trollee
yeah like because all that cuz they just
have to shoot the video make the art
concept put the dude in it and shoot it
and they really never have to commit to
this well the video shoot was probably
probably how much they paid yeah forty
six thousand dollars like marketing so
they're trying to get 2.2 million
dollars I want to go back to the 1970s
or 60s or whatever it is and try a fried
chicken from then to see if it's the
same oh my god that's but then I would
be fair because you've tried so much
different chickens since then well what
if the chicken was better because they
didn't have all these like chemicals and
preservatives and the chicken was
actually tastier and different and they
raised them differently so what if it
tastes different I mean I just want a
time traveling eating chicken because
one thing that I've noticed is but not
before 1950 now use now you're setting
your people really back dude just so
like it eat some chicken
now you're really doing it dude that's
like really bad I went to get KFC and I
want to get and I was like hide in the
bag at the register I was like don't
have paper bags really yeah and it still
had the kernel on it oh my god you
didn't shave I know I walked home that I
you know I walked home but I had to hide
the bag you know my neighborhood is high
traffic and I didn't want anyone then
you know it's funny when somebody got
rolled out the window you would you
would what did happen though was I did
walk by somebody they did give me a
disapproving look and they were black oh
she didn't go to Church's Chicken that's
why you went to KFC skits Popeyes girl
yeah Popeyes or Church's Chicken um see
a black person can see come on now
that's true it was close and convenient
[Music]
[Music]